Hi, I'm Ian Lake.
And I strongly believe
that theming with AppCompat
is what takes your app
from good to great.
So AppCompat uses the pattern
introduced in Lollipop
where you can declare a
set of colors in your theme
which automatically change a
number of elements in your UI.
There's three main colors--
colorPrimary, colorPrimaryDark,
and colorAccent.
colorPrimary is where you start,
and serves as the main branding
color throughout your app.
If you're using a
standard AppCompat theme,
you'll find the app bar uses
colorPrimary by default.
If you're using a
toolbar, set the color
using the background attribute
with attribute colorPrimary.
colorPrimaryDark is only
applicable to Android
5.0 and higher devices, and
serves as the background color
for the status bar, and
should, as the name implies,
be a darker shade of
your primary color.
colorAccent is
slightly different,
and that affects a
wide number of elements
throughout your app.
You'll notice it in EditText
focus, underline, and cursor.
Check CheckBoxes, as well
the background color,
for the floating action button.
Very important that it contrasts
with both your primary color
and your background colors
so it remains legible.
There's a few other colors which
are less often used, but can
be really useful.
colorControlNormal controls
the normal state of components,
such as an unselected EditText.
colorControlActivated overrides
colorAccent as the activated
or checked state for
items such as CheckBoxes.
And colorControlHighlight, which
controls the ripple coloring.
So lots of customization is
possible without touching
any individual components.
But this powerful theming
isn't limited only
to the entire activity.
You could also apply a theme
to any view in your app using
the android:theme attribute,
which lets you change only that
view and its children.
To make this easy, there's
a concept of a ThemeOverlay.
ThemeOverlays,
unlike a full theme,
only seek to change the
few things they need to.
This would be appropriate
for changing elements
in a normally light theme for
display in a dark background,
say an app bar with
a dark primary color.
When building a
custom theme overlay,
make sure your parent theme
is ThemeOverlay.AppCompat.
This ensures that elements
such as colorAccent
work properly on both Lollipop
and pre-Lollipop devices.
So themes and ThemeOverlays
can be a powerful way
to change the look of your app,
either at the activity or view
level.
One more tool to help
you build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]